we saw a kind of shocking story today
that the pastor at the community united
methodist church in pasadena maryland
got a citation last month from state
officials concerning his compliance with
corona law
she reached out to the health department
in anne arundel county maryland for an
explanation
they told us they'd receive complaints
of quote hand shaking
high fives and get this fist bumps
by the congregation now that's illicit
worship
in the state of maryland hard to believe
this is america but it is so they
swooped in to put an
end to that the fist bumps especially is
it legal for our government
to police how americans still protected
by the bill of rights
worship their god in church the reverend
dennis jackson is the pastor at
community united methodist church and
we're happy to have him on
tonight pastor thanks so much for
joining us
thank you so much and let me just say
this is the first i've ever
heard or seen of anything like that
going on
in the context of our church services or
worship i mean we are
very much um sticking to social
distancing
everybody has to wear a mask we have
hand sanitation stations
right as you come into the this uh lobby
and also
right before you go into the sanctuary
um
we have pews marked off to um
to make sure that we keep distances um
we have pews marked out that i think
it's 20 or 30 feet from the pulpit
to make sure that we stay far enough
away
i mean i'm not sure who saw what but
i wonder if there they were in a
different place than i the church that
i'm
serving well i mean it is a church
and you are explicitly protected worship
religious worship is explicitly
protected in the first amendment to the
constitution
so i'm wondering did your governor larry
whatever his name is
jump in on your side here um the
governor i've not heard anything from
nor from the anne arundel county
executive
um about anything like this i was told
there was an anonymous
complaint filed to the anne arundel
county
health department the official that came
out was very authoritarian and
never referenced any of the things that
you highlighted
and if i had seen something like that i
would have
encouraged or very strongly people not
to
to participate in such a thing as that
that's that's
clearly for many reasons not appropriate
um and but we want to maintain religious
freedom and
the ability to worship i mean i'm
preaching at nine o'clock in the morning
in a back of a truck in the parking lot
just so people can gather to worship
yeah well i know you're doing your best
and it's shocking that you're being
harassed like this is so many christian
churches are
in orthodox jewish congregations as well
reverend dennis jackson i appreciate
your coming on thank you
thank you